regardez ces écouteurs vous avez un
écran ici c'est les tours de JBL vous
avez play pause morceau suivant morceau
précédent ici le volume réduction de
bruit active l'ambiance centre vous
venez switcher ici très facilement vous
l'activez vous le désactiver votre
équaliseur vous avez différents modes
studio club basse vocal jazz custom vous
avez ici un petit timer le son si vous
voulez du son spatialisé le Voice aware
le Silent now et là vous avez l'auto
play pause je trouve ça marrant ça porte
un vrai sens à votre étui de
rechargement vous voyez votre niveau de
batterie vous avez l'heure vous voyez si
vous êtes connecté en Bluetooth là vous
avez tout directement sous la main et je
trouve ça extrêmement mal